Mother's Day is this Sunday you gotta
love our moms you know as an earlier
Mother's Day gift or its kind of an
early Mother's Day gift tonight Andy and
I thought we'd do this we thought we'd
give our mom something every mother
loves the sound of their children
agreeing with them right Andy yeah it's
what every mom wants their kid to admit
that they were right all along about
some advice or irrational comment they
made yeah exactly we thought this would
make moms happy Billy it would start to
music please
you're right mom I really should call
more you're right mom single malt scotch
is not a breakfast drink you're right
mom I don't exactly have an HD face
you're right mom you didn't ask for me
to be born you're right mom there should
be more movies where Jeff Goldblum is
shirtless you're right mom they should
give you back your license anyone could
mistake a freeway entrance ramp for a
McDonald's drive-through you're right
mom we'll never really know where Obama
was born by the way anyone else on the
crew have one I do you right mom this
headset does make me look like I teach a
Zumba class you're right mom I should
have learned a real instrument you're
right mom I'm basically holding down
this applause button the whole show
you're right mom upgrading my thermal
coil with the copper alloy should
protect my heat shield against any
unforeseen power surges
I'll try that when I get back to our
planet well thanks everyone and now
let's hear from our whole audience
[Applause]
[Applause]
Mother's Day
yeah
you